It is time for hatred, mail, hatred, mail.
Of course, when a professional voiceover artist
does interpretive readings, interpretive narration
of the hatred mail, the hate mail that I get,
quick reminder about hatred, mail
because we cling to our guns and our God,
but somehow totally cool with a billionaire
who wants to assault our wives.
Hey tree. It may be written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and because
freedom.
All right, let's get right to it. Um, this
pur, I think that the person who wrote this
one to me may not really like my perspective
on politics. Take a listen.
His name, scrawny loser, jealous, low life,
AKA David Pacman is president Trump. David
Pakman is a loser, jealous idiot. We will
fix things by getting liberal hacks like David
Pakman to lose again. David Pakman obviously
drank lots of fluoride and ate from BPA line
plastic his whole life. A feminine loser.
I actually really present this hatred. I didn't
drink lots of fluoride. I got the right amount
of fluoride, the exact right amount, and as
a result, my teeth are healthy. It's a beautiful
thing. Remember that you can fight hatred,
autism in your local community by using the
coupon code hatred@fortywhenyousignupforamembershipatjoinpacman.com
save 40% and make hatred cry with the coupon
code H. a T R I. O T four zero